Speaker 1: Let's instead go to Bishop from
Kentucky. Bishop from Kentucky. Welcome to
the program. Once you unmute yourself, will
be able to talk. And I'm glad to hear about
what's on your mind today.
Speaker 2: Oh, hello.
Speaker 1: Yeah, You're on the air.
Speaker 2: Okay. Um, I just want to talk
about you've seen the recent improvements
of AI, deepfakes and stuff, right? Yes.
Do you think this is ever going to be like
a problem when it comes to like legal cases,
like people could conjure up evidence
that doesn't actually exist and like what
they will realistically sound like and how fast
it's improving? It seems to be a bit worrying.
And I wonder what your opinion is on that.
Speaker 1: Yeah, well, so one of the things
that we've seen when it comes to this
exact sort of problem is whenever some
new technology becomes widespread, which
allows either plagiarism of a new kind or
fabrication of a new kind, you then create
essentially a whole new like industry of tools and
experts designed to authenticate or to determine
is something plagiarism or is a piece of evidence
real or fake? So my expectation would be that if
indeed using these tools to create fake evidence
in trials becomes an issue, there will be a new
cottage industry of experts and tools developed
to attempt to authenticate whether evidence
that is presented is really authentic. Now,
is it possible that the A.I. technology gets
very far ahead of the authentication technology
and it's impossible to authenticate stuff?
Maybe. But usually whenever this happens,
technologies and experts are developed and trained
to then authenticate what that new technology is
making possible.
Speaker 2: Hmm.
Yeah, that's fair. I was. I just like seeing
mostly jokes, like deep fake jokes, like,
recently, like with, like Trump or Biden or. Yeah,
and they're pretty funny, but it's like, it was
like, slightly worrying how realistic they were.
Yeah. The amount of time that it's, like, taken
to, like, reach this level of, um, competency
when it comes to A.I. is like, quite astonishing.
I didn't really think we'd see anything
like it in this, like in my early lifetime,
but it's happening a lot quicker than I thought.
And I just wanted to know your opinion on it.
Speaker 1: It is happening very quickly. You
know, so far the deepfakes of me that have
been sent to me aren't very convincing. But I'm
guessing at some point in the next year or two,
someone's going to send me a deepfake of me and
it'll probably be shockingly realistic. And it
sounds very scary, to be honest.
Speaker 2: Mm hmm.
I'm such a good. Sure that will happen. Yeah.
Speaker 1: All right, Bishop, thank you for
the call. I appreciate it.
Speaker 2: Thank you so much.
Speaker 1: All right. There
is Bishop from Kentucky.